[Applause]
jubilation and emotion as the first
passengers touched down in sydney and
reunite with their families a ban on
international travel was lifted on
monday after more than 18 months and now
fully vaccinated australians are
arriving without having to quarantine
it's a pretty emotional day today um we
lost my father-in-law last week so
it's happy feelings and sad feelings all
at the same time but so glad to see our
family finally sheer
gut-wrenching sadness of why i'm here
uh
but you know you can't you can't fault
the factory at least
i'm here
uh you know so i'm so grateful for that
tens of thousands of australians have
been stranded overseas since the
government closed its borders in march
last year caps on passenger numbers
coming into australian airports also
caused problems for those wanting to
return home during the pandemic it feels
really good i'm actually here for my
dad's funeral
so i've been trying to come home for an
year and a half
for now flights are limited to
australian citizens permanent residents
and immediate families who are now free
to travel without a permit but that
doesn't apply to tourists visa holders
and temporary residents
even when australians do get home travel
across the country is still a challenge
quarantine restrictions still apply in
states like queensland where i am and
the borders are still closed in western
australia to those states and
territories they consider high risk like
victoria and new south wales even the
act which is classified as a low-risk
jurisdiction susie keady is an
australian living in hong kong she is
due to fly into sydney in two weeks time
but she says her travel plans are
complicated by different rules in each
state
it's absolutely a logistical challenge
you know my family has spread across
uh new south wales south australia and
queensland so
you know
so firstly you know getting across the
international border um you know that
was sort of hurdle number one and now
having to navigate the different
restrictions and the different
approaches
to domestic borders um you know remains
challenging
that's a hurdle these reunited families
are willing to overlook for now
sarah clark al jazeera queensland
australia